[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on every story I do you need that
superstar charismatic you know sexy
megafauna species to draw people in in
this case obviously an Antarctic it's
the leopard seal
[Music]
[Applause]
to get in the water with this leopard
seal have it come racing over to me and
do these big threat displacement this is
a seal that's 12 feet long over a
thousand pounds bigger than a grizzly
bear but they're actually intelligent
nurturing caring animals that are very
complex when you look at this tree
historic serpentine appearance of a
leopard suit they're designed for speed
they've got these long pectoral flippers
that when they're on a chase of a
penguin that they can turn those and
they can spin within the length of their
body while doing 20 miles an hour it's
beautiful to watch them hug
[Music]
when the Penguins come to see you see
them get focused they tuck their pecks
in and they're off like Rockettes
boom they grab the penguin
and then you watch how they do the shake
using centrifugal force to turn the
penguin inside out and then they
carefully select the best parts of the
meat off that penguin and then they go
on to the next one
even though they're at the top of the
food chain their main diet is krill and
when you look at bad ice years when you
have really low production of annual sea
ice you get a low production in krill
and that's what's making leopard seals
like every species in Antarctica
vulnerable
[Music]
you